en france la justice n'aime pas se
déjuger ans ni un siècle seulement six
procès ont été révisées celui de patrick
dils pourrait être le septième
l'avocat général de la cour de cassation
en effet demandé aujourd'hui
l'annulation de sa condamnation pour un
double meurtre d'enfant il est établi
que le tueur en série francis heaulme
étaient sur les lieux du drame
patrick dils lui a passé près de 14 ans
en prison
estelle mathieu yves quemener quelques
minutes ont suffi pour comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui quelque chose d'important
était en train de se produire à la cour
de cassation
il est 16 heures tout s'est passé très
vite avec d'abord le départ précipité de
la grand mère du petit alexandre
avec ensuite cette courte phrase
prononcée par le père de patrick dils
côté ça fait 13 ans
il peut encore entendre quelques jours
le visage extrêmement tendu de l'avocat
général de la cour de cassation en
disait long sur la gravité du moment
sans réquisitoire a duré une heure
elle a demandé la révision de la
condamnation de patrick dils
patrick 10 31 ans lui qui a déjà purgé
14 années de prison pour le meurtre de
deux garçons cyril et alexandre c'était
à montigny-lès-metz en 1989 patrick 10
qui avait 16 ans au moment des faits et
qui à ce jour encore est le plus jeune
condamné de france à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
patrick dils qui malgré des aveux crie
son innocence depuis toutes ces années
tout à l'heure comme l'a souligné
l'avocat général le temps de décider est
venu décidée au regard d'un élément
nouveau la présence du tueur en série
francis heaulme sur les lieux du crime
le jour des faits francis heaulme a lui
même indiqué sa présence il a parlé de
sa vision des deux corps il est dessiné
très précisément l'endroit du drame et
il y a dans sa façon de tuer des
similitudes troublantes avec le meurtre
de civils et alexandre à l'issue de
l'audience
il y avait de l'émotion et de la colère
dans les réactions je dis et je le
répète aucun élément encore de ce
dossier ne permet de dire que quelqu'un
d'autre que papa games et commis ce
crime
aujourd'hui on est enfin arrivé et
design c'est un grand jour pour nous
parce qu'enfin
c'est ce qu'on voulait depuis longtemps
que patrick ne soient rejugés devant une
cour d'assises alors là il pourra
s'exprimer
à 18 heures les parents de patrick dils
ont joint par téléphone en 14 ans le
jeune homme a appris à être patient
le 3 avril prochain si la cour de
révision ordonnait un nouveau procès ce
serait une décision historique